The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: In terms of
where we are in the class,
it seems like we
just got started,
but it's actually
the third lecture.
So after the end
of the day, we're
almost 1/4 done with a class.
It's scary.
Yeah, it's bad
news, not good news.
There's another way
to think about that,
which is there's no final exam.
There are homeworks--
they're coming--
and TA sessions.
But part of the
course is for you
to write a research proposal,
not a paper exactly,
but a research proposal.
So that kind of
leads me into what
we're up to today and some sort
of encouragement and caution.
We are trying to do
several things at once.
One, of course, is to
look at particular papers
in the literature as exemplary
of what is out there.
And actually, there, it
matters to get into the details
and really understand
the mechanics
and a few of the surprises.
Some things are not
straightforward.
And even narrowly, it will
raise questions about what
if they had assumed
this instead of that,
or is there some
extension to this model,
or there's something
I just really dislike
about this model?
You'll get inspired.
So we're doing that.
But I'm also trying
to provide overviews
so you can actually see where
these particular trees fall
in the forest.
And I'm not saying it's easy.
It's not easy for me.
And I, for example, spent
the weekend just thinking
about lecture one, lecture
two, and lecture three,
sort of of writing up
English paragraphs about what
are these papers really
telling us and so on.
So my point is be
patient with yourself.
Don't be surprised
if occasionally it's
a bit bewildering because we
are covering a lot of material.
But the reward will come
when you're thinking.
Go back over the lectures,
think about the details
of particular papers.
Maybe think about
it in the context
of your potential
research proposal,
in terms of what you
might like to do,
and I think you'll see
things start coming together.
Yo.
AUDIENCE: Can you
talk a little more
about the logistics
of the proposal?
So one thing is I was supposed
to talk to you before.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: That
would be good, yeah.
As I said, I'm usually around.
I try to stay
around after class.
I'm happy to iterate.
It's like a research
conversation.
You're thinking about x.
You can get my reaction to
it, get Whit's reaction to.
It
AUDIENCE: And how far can we
go from this, from the macro
development into something else?
It has to be something that's--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ROBERT TOWNSEND: We should talk.
I'm not sure what
you're asking me.
AUDIENCE: If I am doing
something that's more
micro-related, would that be--
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Oh, there's a
whole micro part of the class.
We just haven't
gotten there yet.
There's, like, two
lectures away, we
go through a whole
measurement lecture.
And then we spend
almost the rest
of the class talking about
micro tests of this and that.
And then we reintegrate
it and get sort of
moved back toward the macro.
Sometimes I teach
the micro first,
waiting forever to
get to the macro part.
This time we kind of
reversed it the other way.
So micro is fine.
AUDIENCE: And just in
terms of timing, I forgot.
When is the proposal due?
Is it at the end
of your part, or--
ROBERT TOWNSEND: The
end of my part, yeah.
And we reserve the last class,
and I can make it longer.
As many of you as
possible should
think about actually presenting
and getting some practice
at presenting your ideas.
OK.
So today is mostly,
almost all of it,
about limited commitment in
terms of obstacles to trade.
And I'll try to highlight
where that's coming up.
The topic, is of course,
macro-ish, growth, TFP,
inequality.
But it has these financial
market imperfections.
And of course, that's the
bridge back to the micro.
And the introductory
part of this,
where I'm doing the big
picture, the forest,
is broken down into three
segments, one of which
is highlighted, here
but I should tell you
about the other two.
First of all, we're
going to start
talking about transitions.
I was doing that last time.
Some of this literature
is all about transitions
and about financial reforms
or real sector reforms.
There is a second part of this
introductory section which is
entirely about cross-section.
It's comparing one country
to another, and most of that
is in steady state.
And finally, there is the
link between the two, which
is how much of
transitional dynamics
is really going to solve
the entire problem,
and can you save your
way out of constraints
so that steady states look very
different from the transitions,
or is there something left over.
So you start off with what's in
the news all the time, rightly
so, which is China.
And this paper is called
Growing Like China.
And the question
starts with a puzzle.
How can it be that a country
with measured high rates
of return is nevertheless
kind sending its funds abroad
for investing in low
rate of return assets?
And China's in the
news for many reasons,
but among other things,
it's just really
almost the fastest
growth rate in the world,
and there's lots of
structural shifts going
on in terms of sectors and
a lot of privatization.
We have return
investments above 20%.
Savings rates have been
even higher than that.
And China's accumulating-- its
savings well exceeds its demand
for credit, and its
foreign reserves
have to go to
trillions or something,
from $21 billion to
$2,130,000,000 and so on.
So here is another picture.
This is those numbers.
This is foreign reserves
and the difference
between deposits and loans.
And not only is the difference
between deposits and loans
high, it keeps getting
bigger and bigger,
as do the foreign reserves
as a percent of GDP.
You probably know this history.
There was talks of
reforms way back in 1978.
A lot of people date
the real turn in 1992,
although additional
things happened in 1997.
Just to look ahead a
bit, the next paper
we're going to talk about
is where Kaboski Shin,
and they look at reforms
across a bunch of countries.
And they used this 1992 date.
But I think for any
particular country,
it's kind of problematic
to pick one year
and say this is the
year of the reform.
Very high investment rates.
39% of GDP.
Rate of return on capital,
at most, has fallen.
To 21%.
Rate of return on capital in
manufacturing is close to 35%.
Money should be flowing
in there, not flowing out.
This is DPTE, I think, is
developing private enterprise
as opposed to
state-owned enterprise.
And here you can see
early on, in 1992,
the private sector was employing
relatively few workers.
But this has been
increasing so that--
I guess this graph's
ending in 2006.
Private sector is now
like 50% of employment.
And here is the picture of
the share of investment.
And this is a big part
of the story financed
by bank loans, distinguishing
state-owned enterprise
from basically these
developing private enterprise.
So the point is, the
money from the banks
is going into these state-owned,
state-operated manufacturing
and other enterprises.
They're getting something like
35%, if not 40% of their money
not from internal finance, but
externally through these banks.
And the opposite is true.
At best, this is now 10%.
It used to be, like, 5%.
So the private sector
is financing itself
with saving and
internal investment.
So what's the story here?
It's going to be a
story of reforms,
and then this shrinking,
inefficient, state-operated
sector releasing labor into
the rest of the economy.
And in fact, what's
going on here
is even though in principle,
the production functions have
diminishing returns, you don't
suffer from diminishing returns
for a long time
because you can get
all this quote, unquote
labor that's being released
by the other sector.
In some sense we saw this
already with the Thai model
last time, where we had
labor and agriculture
at subsistence wages
being able to flow
toward these entrepreneurs.
That's kind of happening here.
It's not out of
agriculture, it's
out of government, enterprise.
And there are some very
related seminal pieces.
Arthur Lewis, one of the
pioneers of development
economics, and more
recently, Jaume Ventura,
have talked about how you can
prevent diminishing returns
from kicking in.
This is their view
of the literature.
I'm going to skip it.
You can look at
these slides later.
Authors kind of
have different views
of what they do relative
to the literature
than the literature has about
what these guys are doing.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: In China
is there evidence
of in the time series of like
convergence in [INAUDIBLE]
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
I don't remember
the panel aspect of that.
I mean, there is kind
of an average going
on here between these
inefficient state-owned
enterprises and the
private sector ones.
And they go to an
extreme that the return
in the private sector
is basically constant.
If the aggregate's rising,
it's because you're shifting
more and more toward these--
yes.
AUDIENCE: I'm not sure that I
understood exactly the argument
they were [INAUDIBLE].
So was the idea that if I were
a local investor in China,
I want to invest in
the private sector,
but I wouldn't be able to
because that money that
goes into the
financial sector China
is funneled to
state-owned enterprises?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah.
It's not modeled
deeply, but the idea
is there's constraints
on the borrowers.
The private enterprise
sector would
like to borrow because the
rate of return is really high,
and they would make more money.
But there is a simple,
basically constraint
on the amount they're
able to borrow.
So this is the limited
commitment/collateral
constraint.
And that's the break.
That's the key thing
that's preventing the money
from flowing, so they can't flow
from one sector to the other.
It flows out because the country
overall is getting wealthier.
OK.
But this is one of
the papers where
we're going to go and study
the tree in some detail.
And it's trickier than then
this English might imply.
So this is the Buera Shin.
Sorry, this one
doesn't have Kaboski.
As the co-author,
unlike what I said.
This is called Financial
Frictions and the Persistence
of History, A
Quantitative Explanation
so you know a lot of
people beyond China
have remarked on how successful
Asian economies have been
postwar for Japan and so on.
And so they're going to study
the so-called Asian miracle
economies, and they're
going to date the reforms.
And what their paper
is about is basically
if something had been
kind of a roadblock,
and you remove the roadblock,
then these economies
might look like solo economies.
And we'd expect a
very rapid convergence
as capital increases.
But in fact, when you calibrate
these miracle economies the way
you would a solo model at
reasonable parameter values,
although they're growing
remarkably over 20-,
30-year periods, their growth
rates are lower than you would
predict and convergence is
slower than what a simple solo
model would predict.
So they're going to
do this experiment.
Now the thing, again, that's
going to be the key element
here is something like
a collateral constraint.
So you have all this churning
and reallocation going on,
but it can't happen right away.
In fact, investment rates
rise, total productivity rises.
But it takes quite awhile.
What countries are
we talking about?
Japan, Korea-- that's
South Korea, by the way--
Malaysia, Singapore,
Taiwan, Thailand.
Apologies for listing Taiwan
separately from China.
I'm not going to get into
big diplomatic issues here.
And this I already said.
If you want to know something
about the parameters they
stick in, you can look at it.
But here are some
beautiful pictures.
So we have, say, per worker,
GDP relative to the US,
this one is US
worker productivity,
and it's GDP divided by workers.
And you can begin to see the
labels of the countries here.
This is the dating
of the reform.
Talk about 1992 for China.
Each country, they--
heroically, I'm sorry, confess.
I mean, if you read the
history of Korea or Taiwan
or whatever, it's really, really
hard to come up with a date,
but they did.
Thailand is in here.
That's cool because we can
compare it to other papers
and so on.
Japan.
Singapore.
That's per worker GDP.
This is the investment out.
Oh, this black line is kind
of the unweighted average
over all these countries.
TFP.
And private credit
relative, again, to the US.
By the way, this is
that Thai credit boom
we talked about last time.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: How important is the
assignment of the zero date
here?
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
They do not report.
Presumably they played around.
I hope they didn't cook it.
I doubt they did.
I know them quite well.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] And it's
just like in the series here.
It looks like if you do the plus
or minus two or three years,
you still get similar breaks.
Maybe not plus two.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Well,
you kind of hope that--
I mean, that kind of comes with
the fact that things are slow.
Even if you believe that it's
a radical reform, the way they
construct their model economy,
it will happen slowly.
So if you're off by a couple
of years in your dating,
I don't know.
There's hardly anything
here that really jumps.
That's what you're saying.
If you look at that line.
For none of the
countries is there,
like, something popping up.
There's a slide
with interest rates.
I didn't quite understand those.
But that could
just be the reforms
because interest rates are--
however, that said,
ironically, their focus
is on subsidies and taxes
distorting the economy.
And then the reform is
elimination of those wedges,
but they leave the
financial sector intact.
So forget what I said about
the interest rate picture.
So here are these same, or
related variables, GDP, TFP,
investment rates, and so on.
Now keep an eye.
The black lines are--
the light gray line
is the actual data.
So this is what we're
trying to get at.
I think that's an average
over the countries.
And here's this interest rate
one that I don't understand.
But anyway-- oh, and then
there's two other lines here.
The dotted one is
where you basically
eliminate the financing
constraint in their model.
And the lambda they
use, largely, this 1.35,
is the black line.
So what they're
claiming, and you
can decide whether
you believe it or not,
is that largely the data
are close to the black line
and pretty far away
from the dotted line
so that the financial frictions
really help in the explanation.
So I'm frowning when
I'm looking at this.
And then you should be inspired
because this is a famous paper,
I think rightly so.
And they're candid.
Look at the data.
It's like I showed
you my Thai data.
I mean, it's not like
they're hitting a home
run on all these variables.
Some of them look pretty far
away from either prediction.
But again, I think they want
you to see the other end of it,
that the transitions
at the dotted line
are just much faster than
sometimes even in their model,
but certainly,
then, in the data.
That's the point of the paper
is how to slow down the growth.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
So what you're saying
is that the lambda,
1.35, is what they use?
So they basically
say that the reforms
don't eliminate everything.
So there's still a lot of--
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah.
So the idea is you've got these
lazy, untalented, rich firms
that are overfunded because
they're getting a subsidy.
And you've got these lean, high
productivity, private sector
firms--
not state versus private, but in
this case, private with talent
and private without talent.
And then you kind of
eliminate the subsidies end
and the taxes.
And resources would like to flow
to the high productivity firms,
but it doesn't happen
right away because you
jam into these
financing constraints.
So it takes a long time.
Now their model is going to have
forward-looking entrepreneurs.
So these guys who are
talented but constrained,
now not suffering from
taxes or something,
they're going to be
saving at high rates
to try to overcome the
financing constraints.
And eventually that kicks
in, but it takes time
to accumulate capital
sufficiently high value
to be able to collateralized it
to borrow some multiple and so
on.
AUDIENCE: How do
they [INAUDIBLE]??
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
They're using something
like the initial external
finance ratio credit
to GDP, which varies
across country.
Yeah, so it's not--
I don't know which land.
Maybe that was a
particular country,
and I didn't pay
enough attention
when I grabbed their slide.
But it's different, certainly,
for different countries.
And then they make a point
about these companies
hiring more and more workers
and getting bigger and bigger.
And there's something
about factory employment
you might want to
take a look at.
I'm not sure which data
set I grabbed that from.
So the model we've
kind of talked
about how they pick parameters.
Last lecture I
was kind of making
a big deal about estimating
parameters from micro data.
This is more in the macro
tradition, where they're
calibrating parameters or
initial conditions the way
we were just discussing.
So we've said all this.
There is one exercise they do
at the end, where they basically
liberalize the financial
sector, not just get rid
of all the taxes and subsidies.
Their language is a bit tricky.
I read it three or four times
until I finally understood
what they were saying.
They actually said that
helps slow things down.
Now what they really
meant is the target
is better than it
was before, and it's
going to take a
little longer to get
there because the steady
state is quote, better.
But in any event, I'm
not going to focus.
This is practically the
last slide from them,
but you do need to face
choices about what reforms
you're looking at
in a given economy.
And what I didn't say
last time, and this
could have been in
the other lecture,
is that if you look at,
in this case, Thailand,
and you look at measures of
total factor productivity,
you get the usual
sort of factor shares.
Capital has the highest share.
Land, someone asked me
about, is relatively low.
Factor growth, well, this is
the increasing capitalization
of the economy.
And then share times growth rate
kind of makes a contribution.
That factors
contribution to GDP.
And you can see a capital share
is almost equal to the total.
So again, this is
capitalization going on.
And as you get these
shifts out of sectors,
and this is a quick review,
we have the ratio of credit
to GDP on one scale and
financial access on the other.
And you can see this
turning point in 1986.
That's the credit expansion
measured at both the micro
and at the macro level.
And the point here
about TFP is if you
feed that in through the model
we talked about last time,
not only do you get
TFP, can actually
decompose actual TFP in Thailand
into the contribution that's
coming from this financial
deepening effect.
And this is the fit of
the model predicted TFP
to the measured Thai
version of TFP that's coming
from financial deepening.
So roughly, that financial
liberalization in Thailand--
not other reforms, in this
case, just looking at financial
reforms--
actually explains something
like 78% of Thai TFP growth.
And that kind of thing now,
for us, in Thailand, it's
all on the extensive margin.
But for them, all of
their reallocation stuff
is going on the
intensive margin.
There is no sector
in their model
that could not get credit
at least up to capital,
whereas in Thailand,
they just didn't
have bank branches in
many parts of the country.
So it's a different
interpretation.
Now you know not everyone agrees
with what's going on in China.
This paper is about
lifecycle savings.
And they claim that the other
guys are missing the point.
And in particular, savings
rates between the US and China
varied a lot.
And they used to be more
similar than they are now.
In 1988, savings rate
across the household sector
was roughly 5%.
And basically, 20 years
later, savings rate in China
is up to 30% and the
US declined to 2.5%.
And all the while, the
interest rates are coming down.
So this is a puzzle for them.
You know, what's going on?
Well, they construct a life
cycle model, basically.
They construct a
life cycle model,
and they're going to say,
basically, in the US,
young people are
saving less and less.
Guess I should do a poll.
Do graduate students save or
borrow up to your constraints?
But in the US-- sorry,
I'm making light of it--
young people are
saving less and less.
Actually, they're
borrowing more and more.
So the decline in the
world interest rates
made credit cheaper
for young households.
And they're taking
advantage of it.
In China, it's the
the middle aged guys
who are saving more and more.
Now the interest rate could
have gone the other way.
But this is one of these cases
where the income effect trumps
the substitution effect.
And eat now, eat later.
There's two goods.
What's the Engel
curve, so to speak?
Higher incomes have generated
higher savings in China.
So time and time again, the
moral is you have a model.
You may see things
that don't fit.
We already have.
Somebody else will come along
and try to exploit more data,
and either add to the puzzle
or provide an explanation
for things that weren't
fitting so well.
Each model, by
construction, is not
trying to get at everything.
Don't fall into that trap.
It's easy to think, if
only we get it right,
we'll have a totally realistic.
All these models are
abstractions, to some degree,
and they're kind of telling a
story about the growth process
that's informative.
And if there are too
many moving parts,
not only could we not
tell a consistent story,
we're going have
trouble computing it.
So what's very
typical here is to try
to explain why TFP
varies across countries.
There's a huge literature on
this called growth accounting.
And they're going
to attempt to model.
This is where the Hsieh Klenow
stuff, in terms of measurement,
comes in.
But they're going to
feature something not just
in the aggregate.
They're going to feature the
fact that poor, low income
countries not only have low
TFP, they have big differences
across sectors in
terms of productivity
and relative prices.
In particular, the
manufacturing sector
is terribly inefficient
in low income countries,
and the price of capital is
relatively high in low income
countries.
And they'll construct
a model to explain
some of those TFP differences.
So what's the driver here?
And this is one of the trees
we're going to study in detail,
so I don't want to
repeat myself too much.
But the idea they
had, just to think
about how one model
differs from another one,
is to introduce not
only two sectors,
but to have varying fixed costs.
So the idea is this
manufacturing sector,
as opposed to what
they call services,
is the one that has these
very big fixed costs.
So you can imagine that
with financing constraints,
it's very hard for
people to invest
as they might want
to do in something
that requires a lot of
credit because the fixed
costs are so high.
And they embed that
in occupation choice,
so people are choosing
whether to be a worker
or to operate a business in
one of the other sectors.
So as I said, this is all
about cross-country data,
as if every country
were in a steady state.
So they're going to
go across countries
that kind vary in the rate
of, say, external finance
or private credit to
GDP, and see what else
happens in the data as you
go across those countries.
Where do they get
the parameters from?
Well, day one I talked
about Rajan and Zingales.
The other paper
does this as well.
Basically, you act like the
US has wonderfully efficient
credit markets.
A little harder to
swallow these days.
And so things like the firm
size distribution in the US
is as it ought to
be, and everyone
has the same technology, but
they're credit constrained
and the US is not.
So you sort of calibrate
the technology part
of the model based on the
US firm size distribution,
or in this case, manufacturing
versus services as well.
And then you stick that into
these models of the developing
country.
Now quite relevant
to what we're trying
to do in terms of micro and
macro all at the same time
is they take that setup and
do a microfinance revolution.
So again, there's the
usual collateral financing
constraint.
It varies across countries.
And then-- maybe I
can just jump here.
Then what they do,
so people come in
and they have a certain
amount of wealth or assets,
and then decide whether to be
a worker or an entrepreneur.
Normally, the entrepreneur
faces some kind
of financing constraint
that depends on its wealth
and maybe on its talent,
and fee parameterizes
how binding that constraint is.
And here's the revolution,
which is all of a sudden,
you don't have to
be constrained.
You can get a loan which has
nothing to do with your talent.
And whatever your
asset level is,
you get to borrow a fixed
size microfinance loan.
So they embed that.
The point is they're going to
embed it in general equilibrium
and then watch people
choose, kind of do
a controlled experiment.
Actually, what they do
is a partial equilibrium
versus general
equilibrium version.
So we can look at the
partial equilibrium version
first, which basically says
that you start the economy off,
and then you do this
microfinance innovation.
And most things are going up.
Certainly output and capital
are going up over time--
sorry, it's cross-section--
go up as the amount of loan
from the microfinance
sector increases.
All the economies are
alike at the beginning,
but the extent of the loan size
varies in the cross section.
And you can see, the larger
the loan, the higher is output,
the higher is capital
in the economy,
and not much is
happening with TFP.
But it general
equilibrium, and you'll
see this more in a minute when
we go through the predecessor
model, both the wage and the
interest rate are endogenous.
So when you provide credit, you
start shifting the occupation
choice of people.
You start shifting
the amount of capital
they want to set
up and run firms.
That is changing the
demand for credit.
It also, as scale
varies, changes
the demand for employment
starts moving the wage around.
And so the general equilibrium
effects are quite different,
namely output doesn't
move, even across economies
as credit is moving.
Output, TFP, is
slightly increasing.
And the economies are getting
less and less capital.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: How do we
read the [INAUDIBLE]??
How do we read the [INAUDIBLE]?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah.
I guess we'd have to
dig back into the paper
to get at the units.
Part of it is I think
everything has been normalized
to have the same unit.
I think the answer is it's
all relative to this initial--
because all three lines
have the same intercept,
and that's not likely
in any given model.
So this is meant to get at what
happens in the cross-section
as you increase the
amount of credit.
That's why they more or less
all fit on the same diagram.
AUDIENCE: How do you
read [INAUDIBLE]??
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah.
This is, again, a
microfinance loan.
This is just the size
of the loan relative,
I think this is to initial
wealth or something.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] down
because the guys are having
more access to finance because
[INAUDIBLE] we get more capital
because there are less
constrained or something.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: I'm
trying to remember.
It all has to do with the
interest rates and the wages.
I think the interest
rates are going down.
Look at one more picture
and see if that helps.
Otherwise, we'll have
to dig out the paper.
This is for a given
economy as you
fix the level of the
microfinance loan
and then vary wealth.
So it turns out that in partial
equilibrium, more or less,
the benefits are
the same by wealth.
But in general equilibrium,
it's the relatively poor people
who are able to take advantage.
Maybe the wage is going up.
That's part of it.
So those untalented people who
are workers are benefiting.
That has to be true.
By talent, over
here, by ability,
it's not true that
the low ability guys
are the primary beneficiaries.
Basically, the peak is here,
both in general and partial
equilibrium, although
in general, you
can see that the general
equilibrium makes the peak
less, and it drops further.
So the weak statement is
the most able entrepreneurs
in the country are not
benefiting from microfinance,
and they may actually be
hurt from microfinance
when you take into account the
general equilibrium effect.
I think that's also
the wage going up.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So the wage is
starting point 8 Is it
the same all the way to zero?
The x axis?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: I
don't recall enough
about how they calibrated this.
Yeah, it's either the same, or
they've truncated the ability
distribution so the units
actually start up here at point
8 than at 0.
But the point is yeah,
the action is here.
The same comment,
your same question
would apply here in terms of
what is the scale of wealth.
AUDIENCE: It was the same
all the way down to--
suppose that we thought,
oh, this is not a rescaling,
and it shoots all the
way down to the 0.
That would be remarkable
if literally they
were just the same
from point 8 to 0.
And it's like the only
action occurs at the end.
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
Remember, you have
this crucial cutoff about who
wants to be running a firm.
You can be a wage earner,
and whatever the wages are,
they're fixed in equilibrium.
That's the best option for
many, many, many people.
You have to be sufficiently
talented to climb over
that threshold and
want to run a firm.
And when you're running a
firm, you could be constrained.
You could have--
like China, you could
have very high marginal returns,
but with that collateral
constraint, you can't
borrow very much.
So even though you have
this amazingly high return,
you can't exploit it.
So the levels of
profit stay low.
OK.
Well, it may be
frustrating that we
can't go into the details
of this thing more.
But in terms of quote,
the big picture,
you can see them making use
of these kinds of models
to examine a very
relevant experience.
Most evidence we
have on microcredit
is at the micro level, and
it's almost, by construction,
partial equilibrium.
Joe and I tried to remedy that
because Thailand put money
in every village, and the
villages vary in size.
So we actually started to see
the wage moving a little bit.
But mostly, microcredit, as
in RCTs, by construction,
is going to have a partial
equilibrium effect.
But these, what's
going on in Bangladesh?
The whole country's got it.
And we don't see the
country without it.
But that's why we
need the model,
to get to these counterfactuals.
And I'm going to skip
Joaquin's dissertation.
It's on inequality.
It's quite interesting.
And I'm going to skip this thing
about alleviating constraints
in the long run.
But we'll come back
to it in homework
and so on with Abhijit and
Ben Moll on the persistence
of misallocation.
So let's get into the
details of this China paper.
I think you spent some time
at the beginning of class.
So maybe I can get by with
not having to re-motivate it,
and we'll start with the model.
So it is an overlapping
generations.
That's always a bit heroic.
Of course, it makes the
thing much more tractable
because you've only
got, essentially,
two periods of
life to worry about
in the dynamic optimization.
Everyone's got the same
preferences, by the way,
whether you're
going to be a worker
or running a private firm.
And it's over consumption
today and consumption tomorrow.
Theta is a power and beta
is the discount rate.
Workers.
There's not much of an
occupation choice thing here.
Basically, it's almost
as if exogenously, you've
got workers versus
entrepreneurs,
so they downplay that
choice, unlike the paper
we just looked at.
Workers earn some wage.
And what do they
do with the money?
They can put it in the bank
at some interest rate RT.
We'll come back to
that momentarily.
Entrepreneurs are managers
in entrepreneurial firms,
and they earn
something that makes
them want to do that rather
than be a wage earner.
Now I just got done saying
that there's not really
any essential occupation
choice, but that's
because they parameterize
this thing so
that this return that
an entrepreneur can get
is always greater than
the wage in equilibrium
at the parameters they choose.
What can they do
with their money?
They could also put
their money in the bank
at the same rate of
interest, or they
could put it in their firm.
But like we've been
saying, the rate of return
is going to be really high on
internal self-financed savings.
So that's what they're going
to do with their money.
They don't put it in the bank.
So that's higher than the rate.
And some sort of things
to keep an eye on.
The population is
growing at some rate.
I don't know why they did that.
I don't know whether they needed
to get the model paths closer
to the data.
But anyway, that
is in the model,
and I'm not going to
talk about it very much.
Big story is
productivity differences
between state and
private enterprise.
And here's the
production function.
So there's two types
of technologies.
There's kind of a centralized
and a decentralized technology.
The decentralized technology
is going to require managers.
In effect, the
centralized one doesn't
take advantage of
having managers,
and I'll tell you why.
It's pretty artificial.
But for now, just
note some things here.
There is this exogenous
technological progress,
so that's kind of
classic macro stuff.
This A has a T on it.
It's going to be
growing over time.
But it's labor augmenting.
It's not sitting out here
in front of the production
function.
It'll be there in a minute,
but it's going to carry,
inherit this 1 minus alpha
when you pull it outside.
Here's the Chi thing.
So if you're in the
decentralized private sector,
then that technology
is augmented by Chi.
Chi is greater than 1.
Now the idea is, why
doesn't everyone do this?
And even the
state-financed firms,
they kind of tell a story.
And the story is basically--
let's look at the
decentralized firm first.
The decentralized
firm has capital.
Initially, it comes
from somewhere.
But during the production
period, it's predetermined,
and then they can hire labor,
and they can hire managers.
Managers need to be
paid some compensation.
Why this thing?
So the idea here is a manager
can basically steal the output,
walk off with it.
And so that's the psi,
the pitchfork thing.
So that's kind of like
the financial distortion.
That's going to
drive this thing.
The higher is phi, the
more the manager can steal.
And in fact, here's the thing.
They're saying
monitoring somehow
prevents these hired
managers from walking off
with anything, but everything.
But only the decentralized
firms have this monitoring
technology.
The state-operated enterprises
are so darn inefficient
that basically,
psi is equal to 1.
So forget having managers.
So that's the story.
But it's really rigged, meant
to tell a little deeper story
than just imposing a
finance constraint.
So this will be at equality.
You're going to have to pay
the managers that amount
just so they don't steal.
And then plug that
in, and you get
the sort of maximization
problem, which
is now just maximizing.
And you can see, after you pull
out the factor labor, factor
productivity, that you
get stealing is not good.
That lowers it, that
chi is greater than 1
raised to a power,
that raises it.
So this is kind of the
productivity effect
of running a private firm.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
It's fixed so far.
But it's actually going to be
determined in this overlapping
generations model.
People who plan to
be entrepreneurs
in the second period will save.
AUDIENCE: This would have
been identical [INAUDIBLE]..
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah,
you could have done that.
OK.
I said this.
So this is just that
production function notation.
It's the same
production function
for both except for the chi.
And the notation substitutes
in entrepreneurial firms
versus financially
integrated firms.
F for financially integrated.
But they're not efficient guys.
They're inefficient guys.
And here's that
productivity marching along
following this sort of
exogenous mark-off process.
But the important friction
is when I showed you
that problem, or maybe it's
not clear, not so clear yet
that these private enterprise
guys are limited in the amount
that they can borrow.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So the
z is just shock?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: It's boring.
It's boring, but it's a big
part of real business cycle
analysis.
The whole point of
real business cycles
is those aggregate shocks
are driven by basically
something like z or TFP.
So they inherited
that part of it.
I'll show you where it enters.
It's going to generate some
exogenous this growth rate.
But it's not going to be
enough to explain China.
As we were saying
earlier, you've
got to put in some other
financing restrictions
to try to match
up with the data.
OK.
So the rate on
deposits is going to be
equal to the rate at which
you can lend internationally.
This is, like, US
Treasuries, and that's
where the money goes.
Lending, there's a little bit of
a markup, sort of not modeled.
You have to charge more on your
lending rate since some of it
gets chewed up in the
intermediation process.
And this [INAUDIBLE] thing
is basically that markup.
So it subtracts off
from the lending rate
to be equal to the deposit rate.
OK.
So we do a little algebra.
And I'll try to
let you know where
the equations are coming from.
So this kappa, not k, is a
ratio of capital to labor.
But the labor is augmented by
that augmenting technological
progress.
So as you may know, if you've
worked through these things
before, you have a Cobb
Douglas production function.
You want to look for
wages and interest rates.
Well, for example, the
marginal product of capital
will be set equal to
quote, an interest rate,
in this case the lending
rate, because that's
where you can borrow.
And it ends up being--
it is this.
Over the weekend I reworked
all these equations just
to make sure I could
do the algebra.
This one's pretty standard.
Some of them get a bit
tricky, but it probably
is going to take too
much of our time to try
to do it from scratch here.
But I will try to give you
some guidance about what
substitutions are going on and
why they're doing it this way.
The wage is the marginal
product of labor,
and this is an
expression for the wage.
Now that seems odd, except
why not solve for labor?
The point really is that
this is fixed from abroad.
That's going to fix kappa.
And once kappa is fixed,
then basically the wage
is going to be
constant if it were not
for that technological progress.
So the general equilibrium
is made a lot easier
here because they're able
to get these closed form
solutions for the wage
and the interest rate.
So again, where we're going is
resources are going to flow.
Labor in particular is
going to start flowing out
of the state-owned enterprises,
but it doesn't do anything
to the wage.
And the interest rates are
pinned down internationally.
So to the extent the economy's
getting richer and richer
and there's no place
for that money to go,
it's going to go abroad.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
to provide entrepreneurs
with the incentives
to work as manager,
and they have to be greater
than this wage [INAUDIBLE]..
How to guarantee [INAUDIBLE].
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Well, they
set the parameters such
that that's true.
There's always this
tension about where
the parameters come from.
So I'm drawn to micro
data because then I
can estimate something that
I'm willing to believe.
Other people like
to calibrate them.
Now, if you're telling
a story, the story
of China through the
lens of this model
is going to be consistent
with big chunks of the data.
So they're probably just
happy to find a parameter that
makes the story accurate.
Different people have
different tolerance levels.
OK.
So here are these
private sector firms.
After you substitute in for
m in a previous expression
that we just talked about,
it's just choosing employment.
And you get the first
order condition.
Now this is a trick that
turned out to be handy.
Why isn't the wage?
Well, they took the
first order condition
and they multiplied
by n, and they put n
on both sides of this thing.
So there is a
substitution in there.
That's because this
analytic expression--
the wage bill turns
out to get used later
and they wanted an
expression for it.
What is n?
Basically, it's this thing.
So the employment in
these private sector firms
is proportional to the capital.
In fact, many, many
things, almost everything
in this model, is going to
be proportional to capital.
and the thing that
does move, if anything,
is basically this productivity.
But a certain ratios are
going to stay constant,
even if some of the
levels are moving.
So here is the wage.
We substitute that
wage back into 2,
and we get this
expression for the profits
of the private sector.
And the point is this thing
on the right-hand side,
it's just linear.
So despite what
you might thought
would be the
diminishing returns,
the fact is they're able
to hire enough labor
on the extensive
margin at a fixed wage
so they don't get hit with
those diminishing returns.
And for the transition
that they want to analyze,
it's basically what
they call a AK model,
not to confuse the notation.
It's linear, so basically,
Rho is really high.
I'm going to go bananas.
Give me more k.
K is good.
I can make money.
Rho is a lot higher than R.
No, no, no, no.
There's going to
be a constraint.
That's the financing constraint.
But it really helps the
dynamics to figure it out.
So again, what is that Rho?
It's this thing.
And these are all
basically parameters,
interest rates fixed.
Alpha's labor productivity,
capital productivity.
Pitchfork v was a
distortion from stealing,
that chi was this
exogenous productivity
in the state-owned sector.
Everything on the right-hand
side is just a number.
And this thing is
set, parameter choice
set to be greater than 1.
So that's going to be
the driver of China.
And it would happen right away
if it weren't for the borrowing
constraint.
So where do you get money from?
OK, a little lesson on
financing, which you
already know.
But in the notation,
we asked about k.
Where did k come from?
K, at the beginning of the
period, is predetermined,
but it came from last period
saving and from the amount
that they borrowed.
So that's the timing.
And it's the saving of
the entrepreneur who's
going to be running that
firm when they're older,
and they save when
they're young.
OK.
So this L is kind of like
L, liquidity, the amount you
can borrow, could be 0.
But basically you've got to pay
back those loans because you
borrow them at interest.
And so the amount
you've got to pay back
is going to be bounded
by your profit.
And then they're
kind of rewriting
the expression for that.
So we imagine this is binding.
This is where the
credit constraint is.
You're limited to pay back
the loan out of, basically,
next period's profits,
or a proportion of it,
I should say, with factor eta.
So the so-called
leverage ratio, which
is credit to the total
amount of financing,
both internal and
external, is basically
just this fixed number.
A lot of this we've
already talked about.
We just threw in
another parameter.
OK.
So back to the entrepreneur
maximizing utility
with those preferences.
When they're young,
they're basically
getting the managerial
compensation less the savings.
And when they're older, they
get the return on the enterprise
that they're quote,
running, plus
they get this extra kick because
the more they can borrow at RL,
which is fixed, given that
Rho E is higher than that,
they get a return
on the resources
that they got from externally.
So they have money from
their own internal rate,
on their own savings,
and then money
from, quote, profits
that they get
being able to borrow at a lower
rate than their rate of return.
And you can decompose this
into the return, the premium,
and the leverage ratio,
all in a given period,
multiplied by the savings rate.
When we get to
measurement, we're
going to talk a lot about
where does wealth come from.
Wealth comes from saving.
There's a savings
rate, and then there's
the rate of return
you get on saving,
which is like TFP, or
basically factor productivity.
This is effect, with some
leverage, the productivity you
get on given levels of saving.
The point is that this
is all a constant,
so the savings is just going
to be proportional to m.
Now again, I looked at
this over the weekend.
I'm like, huh?
How is that coming from this?
Well, no, no, you got
to go back up here.
And remember, you're going
to get an Euler equation
because you're going to be
sacrificing consumption today
as you say more, and you're
going to get something out
tomorrow with a fixed return.
And given these preferences
raised to a power theta,
you get a nice expression
for the savings rate.
The rate is constant,
and it's just
proportional to their income.
So again, do you like it?
I don't know.
It's special.
But it's part of the algebra.
It's easy to tell
the story in English.
When you get to
the equations, you
realize assumptions
are being made.
Yes.
Question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah.
The way I'm giving
this, probably not
the most complimentary way.
I'm basically saying they're
making up the parameters.
If there's something
disciplining
the other parameters, then
you need eta to be less than 1
in order to be
able to tell this.
And the other papers
in the literature
are clearly doing that.
AUDIENCE: But my question is,
why do you need an extra--
these firms have to
pay their managers.
So the chi has to be--
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah,
it's a very good question.
And we'd have to go--
unless it pops up shortly
in the next few equations,
then I would have to
go back to the paper
and tell you which
particular piece of data
are they trying to fit for which
they need that eta as opposed
to the other things.
So then we get to the
aggregate dynamics.
Well, this is the return
on Firm I. But it's linear,
so basically you can
you can aggregate up.
So you're really
going to use or abuse
this algebra pretty heavily.
The linearity makes it easy
to get the total output
in the entrepreneurial sector.
Now here are some
other ingredients.
We've already seen
that wages and levels
are proportional to output
because of the stealing
parameter.
But output, we already
just saw on the last slide,
is proportional to capital.
Also, managers save a constant
rate out of their earnings.
And we just saw that the
leverage ratio is constant.
So lots of things are constants.
Other things are proportional.
Basically, the capital
stock is the key driver.
And it's moving with exogenous
technological progress.
So the ratio of output
from one period to the next
is the same as the ratio
of the capital from one
period to the next,
and they're all
equal to this common constant.
So the entrepreneurial
sector, therefore, is growing.
We've gone from levels
to growth rates.
That's the point.
So now we can talk
about how fast
is the private sector
in China growing.
Here's the financially
integrated,
inefficient
government-financed firms.
And this is another
expression for output.
This is the output of the
private enterprise sector.
Just to take you
through the algebra
so it's not too
much of a mystery,
they've deliberately gotten
this term in the expression.
That was the whole point of
re-manipulating the output.
And this expression is
something you can figure out
from all the other things we
did on the past four slides.
So you get a simple
expression in terms
of kappa and parameters for this
adjusted ratio of total capital
to total labor.
You start substituting
that in here.
That's where it went.
And you do a little
more manipulation,
and you can get output per
worker in the whole economy.
So this is a version of labor
productivity for all of China.
And of course, output is the
sum of the output in the two
sectors.
Total labor is still n here.
But you can look at output as
a function of labor employment
from these tricks,
controlling for kappa
and this productivity,
and you finally
get the story, the
bottom line, which
is the total output of
the economy is growing.
Why?
One, not too surprising.
It's exogenous
technological progress.
But the other is that
this thing is growing.
So employment in the
enterprise sector
relative to the whole
economy, this thing
is going up because the
enterprise sector is expanding,
drawing employment slowly.
And here are the diagrams.
So one thing, I made a
little joke about Thailand
exhausting agriculture and
no one living there anymore,
and how you got this
knife edge on the wage.
They also have the
same thing going on.
At some point, this process
slows down or stops.
Now eventually, you'll
draw employment out
of that state-owned sector.
It will disappear.
And at that point the wage
is going to start to go up.
This isn't totally realistic
because the wages are rising
in China, to some extent.
But they were low
for quite a while.
I don't know.
The date's supposed to be 1992.
Yes.
This is the firm
employment share, which
again, goes up until it hits 1.
So you see the parallel
with what we did before.
It's just we've
relabeled the sector,
and the algebra and the
assumptions are different.
But here you get output
growing, and then
you hit the sort of
diminishing returns at cap
T. Is the end of China.
No, just kidding.
I keep looking at these guys.
The T is when you've exhausted
this transition process.
And here's the foreign
surplus to GDP.
We'll get to that in a minute.
And here's the
aggregate savings rate
going up very dramatically.
So by the way, that
demography paper
that claimed other
people don't get
an increase in the
aggregate savings rate
is wrong because it is
happening in this model.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Do we know from
later on the data from China
on, I guess, state and
private employment,
and also, like
you're saying, data
on the wage, if we're
to believe this model,
how long the
transition will go on.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Well, I
guess that's the key question,
and I don't think
they focused on that,
unlike the previous paper.
The data, you're reminding me
to say something about that.
So they actually
look by, I guess,
it's province within China.
And they're saying that areas
with growth in private sector
employment are areas that are
basically having high savings
rates.
So they're actually fitting
it a bit within the country.
The other thing I remember
to say is China Data Center.
So as per our continuing
conversation about GIS,
there's a --they're
housed at Michigan,
partly funded by Michigan,
but also Purdue and the Luce
Foundation and so on--
and they are putting tons
of data on GIS archive,
and you can generate maps.
Actually, MIT is a subscriber,
so you can get a lot of this
if you go to MIT GIS.
You can find China Data Center.
I actually put it on my
syllabus and I'd forgotten
to mention it up to this point.
So there's probably a
lot of interesting things
you could do with
the Chinese data.
I'm not saying they have all
of it there, and some of it's
confidential.
All right.
Here's the story of
the capital outflows.
You've got investment.
Well, you've got deposits.
Little lesson on flow of funds.
You've got the deposits
coming from the workers.
Wages times employment.
And they're going to put
that times a parameter.
They do eat some.
And that money has
to go somewhere.
It can go into investment,
or it could go in lending
to the rest of the world.
And they actually
solve this equation
with all this other
algebra, which
by now is too bewildering.
You wouldn't be
able to replicate it
right off your head.
But basically, this borrowing
is coming from a constant term,
lending to the
rest of the world--
funny thing to call it--
B is coming from a constant term
this increase in TFP, partly,
that's driving it,
and then this thing.
So the big story
here is that when
the state owned enterprise
sector is shrinking,
it's releasing resources.
They're the big
borrowers, and so they're
borrowing less and less.
So that's a big part of
the money going abroad.
OK.
So I'm going to just
settle on giving you
an outline of this paper and
let you look at the slides
at your leisure, so to speak.
This is the motivation
we've talked about,
which is relative prices in TFP.
Let me find key equations.
So there's two
sectors, and there's
a fixed cost, which is
higher in manufacturing
than service sector.
There is this entrepreneurial
ability, and there's wealth,
and then there's
this credit friction.
Now again, this
production technology
looks like Cobb Douglas.
It has decreasing
returns to scale,
but it's augmented by z, which
was a, sort of a version of it.
And now what makes
this more challenging
is it's supposed to have
a realistic optimization,
infinite horizon.
Everyone is maximizing
discounted expected utility.
There's no heterogeneity.
But good luck solving this.
They do, or partly computing.
So it's sort of a CDS.
There are two goods, the service
sector and the manufacturing
sector.
And this pitchfork thing is sort
of the weight between the two.
You're picking up
parameters, by the way.
Be mindful of that.
Beta, sigma, something
that looks like an epsilon.
And this phi.
And there's going to
be a calibration slide.
They're going to have to
choose all of these and others.
So here's a picture
like the one I showed.
From the point of a
person, you start off
with a certain amount of
wealth from previous period,
and then you get a draw
of your talent, which
can vary depending
on whether you
go into the small
or the large sector.
You could be a worker and just
work and produce and consume.
Or you could go into one of
these sector J's and produce.
This is work.
This is produce and consume.
Now this gamma, this is a
bit more realistic version
of talent or productivity.
This z that you have
at the beginning
is likely to be the
same at the end.
But every so often,
you lose your ability,
or this is a stand-in for
sectors that are changing
in an unmodeled way here.
In fact, they're going
to draw this parameter
from exits of firms in the US.
Bad stuff happens, you
have to go out of business,
technologically.
So you have these
value functions.
They're going to
have to iterate.
You have ability
and wealth today,
and you're going to
try to maximize wealth,
your value for
wealth and ability
tomorrow with your
contemporaneous utility,
the choices.
This is classic, very
limited market-type stuff.
You basically
[INAUDIBLE] or save.
Maybe you could borrow
if this goes negative.
You've got uses and
sources of resources.
You've got your wealth with
interest today, and the wage
if you're a worker.
And you could either
eat it or save it.
Now this p is because capital
is denominated in units
of the manufacturing good.
So we've got a price, not just
a wage and an interest rate,
to worry about.
If you're an entrepreneur, it
looks a lot more complicated.
But actually, this is the
key financing constraint.
So your capital can be
higher than your wealth.
But it's limited, and I'll show
you where it's coming from.
So otherwise, this is
like that LEB thing.
You've got profits,
and then if you're
in the intermediated sector,
you have this return on wealth.
Basically they could have
done it many, many ways.
They just basically say, you
can run off with the capital.
So the idea is you borrow.
You don't have to repay,
but you pay for it.
You lose the collateral,
which is the wealth you had
squirreled away in the bank.
And then from then on,
you're on your own.
So they get of this
autarchy thing,
and the borrowing size is
limited by the temptation
to run off into autarchy,
despite the loss of wealth,
because you get to keep that k.
But you do have to pay
workers, for some reason.
Never quite sure
why they did that.
OK.
So then what they
have to do is compute
the stationary equilibrium,
which is basically a mapping.
You've got all these many
people with different wealths,
all these many people
with different talents,
and you get this mapping
till it settles down.
That's what a
stationary steady state
means, that those
histograms settle down.
And at the steady state, you'll
get interest rates and so on.
So they start
grabbing parameters
to match firm size
distributions.
They aggregate up.
They have the lazy
entrepreneurs who
aren't so talented versus the
poor guys who are talented
but have very low wealth.
And that's what's creating
the credit friction.
We've talked about that.
And then they try to match.
Now again, is this bragging
rights, or is it a sad story?
So you can decide here.
Basically, these
diamonds, they're
calibrated predictions of
capital output, TFP, and worker
as you vary across countries.
And the data are all down here,
in many of these instances.
So clearly a lot more to do.
But up to the point
that they wrote this,
no one had done anything
like this before.
So I think I'll
just skip the rest
because I want to end on time.
So thank you.